kay.
Let's do some audience questions for the week.
Some, uh, good ones.
I'm looking forward to answering today.
First one is from [inaudible].
Hey David, why does your show have a mostly
male audience?
Well, this is actually, it's not just our
show.
This is a general dynamic for shows like ours
in general.
And this is something I've talked to a lot
of people about.
I know a Sam Cedar and I have talked about
this and I've talked about it with a lot of
folks over at the young Turks and it just
sort of a tough nut to crack.
And what it really comes down to is that fundamentally
online news and politics has a male audience.
So it's not so much about the shows, it's
about the format.
I don't have a single close female friend
I can think of that watches my show or shows
like mine.
I mean period.
They, you know, they're sort of tangentially
aware of my show because they see stuff on
Facebook for example.
But nobody that I know who, um, uh, is, is
a woman regularly says, oh yeah, I watched
the young Turks or Sam Cedar or whatever.
And it is really common for shows like the
David Pakman show to have anywhere from 60
to 80% male audiences.
I think our podcast audience is, has a little
more, um, a female to male ratio in it.
The youtube channel is more male than the
podcast, for example.
Hard to get data from radio or from television.
And part of it is the format, which is, it's
just a format that is more heavily watched
by men.
Part of it is also story selection because,
um, if you look at studies about which stories
were more followed by men versus more followed
by women, when you look at from Pew Research,
for example, the news stories that were more
followed by women than men.
It's all stories that we didn't cover.
Okay.
So the coal miners and Utah was a news story
that was followed more by women than by men.
Um, contaminated pet food.
We didn't cover it.
Maybe it got a mention on the bonus show,
the Chinese toy recall, um, a variety of kidnappings
of kids that I don't even remember at this
point over the years.
The story about drug resistant staph infection
spreading, we didn't cover or barely covered
any of those stories.
So it's also story selection.
If you look at stories like for example at
Venezuela, uh, the Supreme Court, immigration,
Iran, those are stories that were more heavily
followed by men than by women.
So in short, you've got to format that in
general is more watched by men than by women.
And then you have stories selection within
our show, which also seems to not be including
some of those stories that were followed more
close closely by women.
Uh, and that's sort of where you end up.
Now.
I am not considering it sort of a forgone
conclusion or sort of fait accompli.
We are actively talking about how can we increase
our female following and uh, you know, there's
little things that I do.
One is, uh, with voicemails when we get voicemails
from women, I make sure to try to get more
of those voices represented because it creates
this vicious circle.
If everybody you hear leaving a voicemail
is male and your female, that might be a disincentive
to even call in.
So, uh, same thing with phone calls.
We've got some great female callers including
valve from Agawam who we love and when she
calls in we just try to, you know, include
more female voices and also with guests selection.
There is actually a big discussion, um, that
happens in general when doing analyses of
news media that they're not only is there
a big corporate skew of so called experts
on news media, there's also a major male skew.
And so, uh, since overwhelmingly the guests
that we get pitched our men, we also make
sure that for the guests that we decide to
go after and invite to the show that we're
including a, uh, a mix.
And we've had some really great female guest
as well.
So that's what we're doing.
But there are some sort of systemic issues
that explain a lot of why that is.
Now if you say, why is it that online news
and politics does not appeal to women as much
as it does to men?
I don't have the answer.
Um, and I'd be curious to hear from you what
you think might explain it